au nord du 55e parallèle l'hiver n'est
pas créé il est célébré et pendant une
semaine Ford Beck Mary devient un peu
l’épicentre de toutes les communautés
polaires
[Applaudissements]
2000 athlètes et délégués sont réunis
ici pour les Jeux d'hiver articles un
moment il oubliable pour ses jeunes qui
viennent pour la plupart de petites
communautés isolées un événement
incroyable pour eux puis ça leur donne
une opportunité d'ouverture sur le reste
du Nord des dizaines de supports sont
représentés mais les jeux Dénés et
articles occupent une place particulière
si compétitions mettent par exemple en
lumière des ébulottés essentiels pour la
chasse ou encore reproduisent des scènes
traditionnels de la vie des Premières
nations nordiques
pour les jeunes athlètes ces jeux
représentent beaucoup dans l'équipe du
Groenland tous partagent les mêmes
émotions après la victoire d'une des
leurs
important pour moi c'est toute ma vie
dit la jeunette du 13 ans fier d'avoir
battu un corps personnel en
les exploits sportifs sont célébrés mais
les jeux articles sont plus qu'une
compétition athlétique l'évilement
occupent une classe prépondérant dans la
vie des communautés nordiques
[Musique]
nous avons développé une famille unique
dans l'article explique l'entraîneur de
l'équipe du Groenland
et qui dit jeu article dit ok parmi
toutes les épreuves d'autres
traditionnelles elle demeure une des
plus populaires d'occasion aussi pour
les parents de vivre l'expérience
[Applaudissements]
organisez tous les deux ans les jeux
servent aussi à perpétuer des traditions
plus que centenaires de génération en
génération depuis 1970 il constitue une
façon pour les jeunes athlètes de
relouer avec leurs racines je pense que
c'est important de garder les traditions
vivants avec les générations aussi la
technologie du sol la culture se perd un
peu puis le fait de mettre ça en premier
plan ici ça les aide à reconnecter avec
justement leur culture
[Musique]
une place importante est faite aux
cultures nordiques des délégués viennent
de tous les coins de l'article pour
mettre en valeur leurs tradition comme
cette chanteuse de la communauté
autochtone de Norvège
dehors comme à l'intérieur une semaine
d'activité pour en apprendre davantage
sur les autres au-delà des épreuves on
souhaite surtout créer des ponts en
protocole et à l'automne je me trouve
que je me rapproche alors culture et que
je peux plus comprendre de où ils
viennent
et comme le vu la tradition durant ces
Jeux tout est fait pour créer des liens
des épinglettes Camènes a vécu les
délégués deviennent des objets des
changes très convoités un incontournable
des jeux d'articles
dans le froid de fortnite Mary pendant
une semaine si le sentiment
d'appartenance au nord qui se construit